welcome to this video for Round four of
the Todd Memorial 2013 and tongue let's
get right to the game's first game is
murasa which against crumb League and
more was playing efore and chronic place
as usual 1e5 he am pretty much stopped
playing the Petrov I really think he
concentrates on the Berlin nowadays but
we get Knight c3 on all three and
transposed to a scotch opening in fact
this Scotch fall nights Kramnik has
played himself as white surprisingly a
couple of times against our own young
and now Rosa [ __ ] playing this line
yeah this is very much the main line
both thighs side some really have a hard
time to deviate you can but this is like
the ninety percent of all games main
line here chrome nick has played from
the white side chrome nick has played
them move 83 which yeah i mean this
cannot really be the refutation of
blacks play but ok it cannot be refuted
anyway so what I'm getting at is that
age 3 is certainly not a bad move but
not a move that really sends a shiver
down your spine it's just kind of useful
move covering g4 and preparing a queen
to have three um I don't think that
blackens in any big trouble after that
as well but a moral plate the
traditional main move Bishop g5 Kramnik
plate c6 covering this important pawn
and Queen f reduces the overwhelming
main line actually with queen of three
here crumbling
a bishop to d6 this is some one of the
well-known continuations there's also h6
which is then the driveway to play it as
some right now can capture and play this
kind of setup this is in fact one of the
safest lines in the whole of chess
letter no I mean this is the kind of end
game where I should really draw against
any sort of opposition um okay but
chronic play Bishop b6 which is a bit
more interesting age 3 covering the
important square here against those kind
of moves it's a technical thing and this
is not so easy to play ball anyway but
h3 is useful rook p8 very important
attacking the spot and the rook
sometimes even can be useful or before
for example after moves like h6 Bishop
h4 look before wins the temple b3 hunter
s ting decision this very often this
route p8 move the sunset by 91 later to
a3 b3 allows Bishop to e5 which looks
bit uncomfortable at first I in the
snide and it cannot move because of them
the pin but Dwight has a technical reply
Bishop a form using nodus tag and I know
we get a a force sequence crumbling took
here which is the best move you
shouldn't really do that this is some
helping white somewhat what dream is
Queen on d4 and night here locating the
dis pawns on light squares this would be
M quite an achievement for white so
black is avoiding that just taking on c3
is good takes here takes on a one so we
have this secrets of captures and now um
white would be substantially better
wasn't for the move played now Bishop g4
is very strong with the temple on the
Queen and this can be Casa Bishop is
taken and now this specialist take it so
we have a simplification with a night
left against bishop the bishop is some a
good piece in an open kind of position
but this this is all this is an open
position in a way but here the night is
also a good piece simply because if we M
continue for one or two moves like this
now in this kind of position this night
is not easily disturbed it is positioned
on f6 and it can only be attacked with
g5 where is always taken besides them
those kind of moves and the mangy fibers
completely nonsensical um what I'm
getting at this is a quite stable post
for this night and it can always be used
even on a more central square this
Bishop it helps to set up this battery
but you never get the meydan h7 so this
Bishop might be pointing into thin air
in the game Morrow played see for taking
this pawn maybe trying to isolate it on
d5 and Kramnik played the bushes moved
before you also could have played
something like this we're not much is
happening really but device is not bad
c5 this is necessary i think if why did
play some some sort of lazy moves now
let's let's say this black gum I can try
to set up a position with c65 for
example rukia and c5 this could could be
an idea of the general idea and after
that black may improve with queenie aid
and so on this looks quite nice
c5 is got it keeps this pod unsupported
and maybe this can be a weakness later
yeah rook 25 and rook and queen e 8 so
chrome leaguers playing for active PC
give up gives up the porn and activates
with rookie 5 Quincy three at the Queen
needs to watch over this Bishop and here
in fact Kramnik played a slightly
inaccurate with Queen e7 he could have
gotten a pretty decent position for
example here before and Nyjah for the
big idea is that after rookie one black
plays rook takes d3 and just wins the
game important technical shot the thing
is in the game he didn't play Queen e7
and before he didn't insert this pair of
moves he in me he instantly took and now
after he won this queen is attacked with
the check so rook to e3 of course loses
the house and this means this slightly
slight problem what is black doing now
he played the Queen d7 he could have
gone in rookie 5 as well but this end
game after the capture is also I'm not
very comfortable this Bishop placed on a
phone or maybe at g2 later being more
stable is always putting this pressure
on c6 and why just got three against two
points so in the long run he can maybe
push pawns and the porn on the other
side is not so terribly important this
is some quite quite a tricky and game
you played 27 Bishop b4 b5 and in this
position here this is the key position
of the game here and moral could have
played a bishop to f3 and this leads to
a similar endgame
described before after taking for
example and now something like f5 reform
this kind of endgame we've got an
excellent bishop always pressurizing the
pawn and it is quite quickly and b5 c6
the pawns I think why does yeah what is
probably close to winning this pollution
chrome legs inaccurate move 24 william
could have gotten into huge trouble but
in the game we played f3 and he maybe I
don't know overlooked this yeah now
after this black takes the end is even
better after before this was saying as
well there's f5 maybe he miscalculated
something in the in the complications
that that are coming up now they're here
white doesn't have much choice need to
grab this night and no black took the
bishop and get from first glance you
think okay maybe the sea porn is even
dangerous but it's at hartley possible
to to get some to something substantial
white also always has this counter play
we will see him with with the queen with
all these checks and the spins in fact
right here after the throw the
repetition a draw was agreed which is a
fair result here both sides have have
problems too to make any sort of headway
so I'm arose which really had one big
chance instead of f3 hit Bishop f3
getting into this mix and game with
Queen and minor piece against Queen a
minor piece where the bishop is the much
stronger unit yeah but of shame for more
oh he could have really puddin put much
pressure on
chrome neck okay um let's go to the next
game on I'm dragging against Carson we
have a symmetrical English and cousins
playing with an early d5 this is an
interesting line for black at some it
yeah it gives you some chances to earn
even on play ambitiously 444 etches
black if white plays very timidly like
let's say white place very often play
something like this just for why are you
and sake this is this reverse maroc see
point where black can easily be better
if white plays in a sluggish manner this
is g3 but there are other move so I for
example and have played you for a couple
of times this is some bit of an old
fashioned move but it's still
interesting this kind of line it's too
interesting interesting claim it can
still be recommended black players
probably have forgotten loss of the
theory um but another interesting line
is III and this is plague nirbhaya
unbreaking um yeah causal now
surprisingly place the move to six in
fact I always thought this move would be
a would be bad but um and Reagan doesn't
play the prescribed um antidote he
played the Bishop b5 check which isn't
bad but well back when i played a 383 i
have studied this years ago queen bee
three was the argument against g6 the
idea being that if black takes now
quincy three is very embarrassing
attacking the rook and the porn so why
twins upon or black yeah also needs to
play very am ugly moves like FC
for instance after which you can even
think about just playing Bishop c4 I
mean this looks crazy f6 um okay black
obviously doesn't take but what are you
playing if you are not taking this is
the problem let's say night here there's
always there's also this idea of going
knight to e for taking the service pawn
and black maybe can try to sacrifice it
but it always was considered to be
somewhat better for white so bit
surprising that why did then didn't go
for that he played as mentioned he
played Bishop to b5 check Bishop d7 yeah
this possible move tactically 95p should
be father's grateful black and the
capture is also nothing a queen bee
three was played and took on c3 yeah
here white played Knight to e5 hopefully
move threatening and made on f7 um let's
look at the turn just quickly Quincy
three is actually a big error now after
this black gets a just winning yeah
something like this it's not defensible
just too much this also 96 long castles
and this is just an exchange for porn
even and whites position as a disaster
so we cannot play Quincy three but be
Texas reham was certainly worth
considering the idea being to just push
d4 and Bishop e3 this kind of setup um
what's interesting not bad at all it's a
bit similar to groom felt but not quite
yet 95 was played of tricky move
yeah as mentioned threatening mate and
yeah what should like do I think I'm
program probably need to do that here
but it's not another problem wyd
captured and now cousin decided to
simply clarify this position and get get
all the pieces off it's a quite
impossible to do anything on ambitious
this black here not much else than b6
and after Bishop t6 now yeah y term
doesn't have any great alternative to
capturing Knight f3 back it's also quite
quite nothing to be honest so he took it
played a four a five long castles quite
yeah no not so it not unexpected move
but the king is quite useful here on the
queenside to defend it after a five and
that's not much else black exchanged and
played bishop c7 and here we actually am
already see that it is very difficult
for for white to make any kind of
progress the only weakness that black
has to be six porn after the capture on
b6 and this is defended by the bishop
and this is one of those cases where
yeah bad bishops protect good pawns this
funny figure of speak created by
romanian grandmaster Shuba yeah it's
often quite quite correct important
points are covered by bad bishops yeah
but then what is why it's supposed to do
was supposed to do this weaknesses is it
this week but how do you attack it
protect it with rooks it doesn't help
this bad bishop is defending it and you
cannot attack it with this visio bishop
which is a good bishop but it doesn't
detect anything so one long story short
black puts lots of pawns on dark squares
but there's simply no I had way
what so ever captured and now cards even
deliberately puts everything on dark
squares to close the position and on the
a file we have the rooks coming off and
game drawn here yeah kind of position
where you can basically instruct people
even even with without if they are
knowing the rules of chess to to make a
draw against the word class play I
simply need to shuffle the bishop and
take every porn that is presented to you
in case there is some desperate attempt
it's just completely dead and yeah quite
an quite a dull game what what can you
save it it's quite quite strange that he
didn't play cooing be through him but ok
it was I think it was a try to get
something on in a forgotten line I mean
it's not g6 is just one response he had
here there are other interesting ideas
for example on what what I analyzed back
then I remember that was this this
continuation yeah which was quite
interesting for white and during their
room it's not this this kind of dull on
game didn't arise before sometimes had
just happens there are many interesting
lines here for white but it simply
didn't accept it didn't happen ok um yes
which to hunt against galfond and it
won't spend so much time on the game it
wasn't a bad game not at all it was if
you look at it a bit i think it was
almost yeah it seems like no both
players didn't make any kind of mistakes
so it's some
frankly not so much happening we are at
the same opening as in cards against
them gelfand from the candidates and we
simeon a lame get this kind of structure
this also happened and the girlfriend
calls again but Carson galfond game but
here girlfriend went for a Bishop d7 set
up with the exchange on d4 and Bishop c6
and here now it plays with 95 this is a
possible improvement age 32 cover g4 and
can put a couple of moves on the board
White's idea is to make us long term of
this three against two pawns maybe push
those pawns in the long run and also
he's got a slight lead development White
has got all pieces in play including the
looks some more somewhat involved well
black and black hasn't connected rook c8
and this Queen too much paint the screen
on d 8 is some Mia it doesn't have a
comfortable spot really so I'm why it
has a little something and he kept in to
be something for the whole game but it
never really um yeah came to something
waiting okay why this may be winning it
was always nice looking and like this
isn't isn't this nice looking this
Bishop is blocking the porn you can you
can attack here but it's know your
progress yeah oh here after this
exchange and before white white is
certainly somewhat better I mean this is
a good piece you've got three against
two with the potential passer later on
the queenside but having a nice position
no a nice-looking position and actually
winning a game is quite a difference and
it it's simply that also
girlfriend is an excellent defender he
centralized the king and got rid of this
strong piece this is always a good
defensive method if you are not quite
sure what's the best defense look at the
best piece of your opponent look at your
worst piece and if you manage to
exchange it it's usually very helpful
procedure the knight on f6 wasn't
especially bad I mean it's not doing
much look at those squares they are all
controlled but it's clear that this
night on c5 is an annoying piece it can
never be really attacked because of this
so you want to get rid of this piece and
this means oops 97 is a very logical and
good news yeah and why it has no real
way to to avoid this you can drop back
but this is actually not really nothing
getting into this into this ugly pin so
we had the exchange and with the those
exchanges and a pretty decent blockade
of the pants it's clear that black ass
in no trouble whatsoever it took the
default and now exchanged even more
that's a really hard to suggest anything
else it's a very straightforward very
correct game which unfortunately happens
to end in a draw because simply they
don't make any mistakes white played for
the c6 and now we have from the straight
black cannot avoid the loss of the b5
pawn and here draw was agreed afternoon
for tea maybe they have a 40 move entire
draw pool or something they could have
agreed earlier yeah it says it sometimes
happens i think we she had a little
something this kind of position here is
a minimal somehow little advantage but
it never really materialized that it's
enough to win and that seems that again
it seems like girlfriend did an
excellent job offer
stop defending the position it's not
much fun but yeah it happens in your job
it's not always fun okay so the next
game is kayaking against Mammadyarov and
we quite surprising me get a perk
defense or puts defense on surprising
because this isn't the most popular
opening on the top level nobody are off
once yeah once in a while place this but
usually and Blitzen rapid and not in n
tournament chess mm early Bishop d3
interesting not quite sure what this is
doing quite curious I prepared of course
a little bit for for the video and I
wasn't really aware that this move all
of us choose chosen the thing is so
Knight f3 oops this was so strange
Knight f3 as the overwhelming main moves
after which black can cancel what play
see 5 which is the more tactical moves
let's say a more direct move that can
get the very complicated quickly with
this kind of complicated variations or
black and castle as mentioned after
Bishop e3 can play all kinds of news
night a six-night c6 and in fact c5
doesn't have a great reputation the fun
thing is here merger of castled night a
free and unplayed c5 and actually it
really has a bad reputation the smooth
um strangely enough after taking the
normal move of course is just to
recapture but this after a five leads to
some edge for for white simply because
the spawn CM that if I
pawn it done it blocks this bishop and
this means that white has some some edge
for example let's say something like
this and then this moves also Bishop
before coming putting pressure here this
is a really nice position for wide okay
why did the moment gaurav play this okay
he had an idea obviously and the ideas
night BTW 7 and in fact in my database
of 5 point something million games this
position only only a was on the board
one time just one rather unknown game
and what is night bd7 near white of
course takes now on d6 and black
recaptures so black has sacrificed the
pawn right here on move 8 and does he
have enough compensation to be honest I
don't think so but what like has he's
got some ideas night c5 attacking me for
rookie eight you can detect the center
in various ways but it still looks
strange to me that you should be able to
sacrifice the spawn it's also quite um
quite weird because um if you give it to
a computer and meridian off I don't know
had I would expect that he had prepared
this the computer also gives white a
very substantial advantage kya can
always place a 4 here so if you play the
pets you you know that you will play
this usually and so this is maybe really
a preparation by mohmmad yaariyaan yet
spent like seven minutes here but if you
look at this now castles was played
through p8 and 83 so useful move to em
to cover the square prevent possible
Bishop g4 later on other pieces to g4
yeah in this position it's not clear to
me what want blacks plan is if you play
something exists for example you just
play you five and dumb and I don't think
it's enough compensation really in the
game he played this quite astonishing
move of course you need to yeah go for
extreme measures you cannot play play em
slower maneuvering chess with this pawn
down okay b5 it intends to play before
and getting to the porn so what needs to
take it and Andy took it with the night
night if all this was the idea of your
sleep takes yeah this this is not really
helpful lose because oops no this is
saying so you cannot take here because I
push overhead so this was simply plate
96 look back and now wider yet to
concede to clarify matters and yeah what
this white is two points up really and
yeah this never is enough compensation
for two points but in fact it is not so
easy to play I mean black Scott more
more pieces in play the rooks especially
our I good this is a good bishop and why
this slightly passive with lots of
pieces on the back rank it's simply this
case if you give away two pawns if it is
sacrifice or even just the blunder if
you give away two points you get open
files simply the consequence if you toss
away your pawns you you have space for
your pieces and therefore black has some
compensation but it shouldn't be enough
for two bonds okay rookie one he wanted
to get rid of one of the active rooks
this was
cessful and here we see that yeah black
soap it's broke the 894 let a for he's
got some activity night d 3 plate yeah
and he I think black gum could have
obtained quite good counter play with
Ruby age increasing the pressure may be
intending to take and play Queen 86
winning this bond so if white plays a
nothing yeah let's say this one just for
argument's sake then this this line and
black will get get the pawn and still
remain active so oops rooty eight this
is what I need to show setting up this
this pin can be answered by Bishop to
deform and after the capture there's
also this f porn hanging in addition to
the beep on so let's say something like
this keV us the beep on but not this one
and this is some in a position where
black and can put up very stiff
resistance justjust upon down compared
to two bonds and active pieces they
played the capture on d3 and then after
that it seems with white returning one
pawn he can activate the pieces enough a
foreign he keeps the pawn still black as
fairly active so it's not all lost ya
here black I should probably play and
flag Luke the age attacking the mission
what you shouldn't do is when he played
he played Queen a one and this has a big
drawback here white could have improved
his chances considerably by playing luke
2d three and tend a group d 7 and this
rook activation on the seventh-ranked
attacking f7 isn't head very hard to
prevent it seems that this should should
really win for white
instead he played rook to e1 and after
Queen B to look the eight black Scott
activity this ruckus just passively and
just compare our going on the seventh
rank and now it's on you won again and
now I'm it still is a bit of something
for white but black in fact defended
them cautiously but consciously is wrong
word it offended correctly and an active
fashion and not playing any any passive
moves so when this was lost but blackest
is just far too active him to be in any
substantial trouble get the king let's
try to initiate counter plane yeah go
for utmost activity after takes h4 here
it was a great drawn let's say this
check King moves and through gate seven
and there's absolutely no way for whites
to make any progress this pawn is always
attacked and if you move away the rocker
it is it is gone can place something
like this but this is also zero progress
and after here and f5 this is one next
so it's it's a dead ROI and it wasn't
reach drawn between those seven those
two there was probably something for
whites I mean after this Queen a one on
move 20 form there was one big
opportunity here with the route to d3
and very weird opening choices with c5
takes and night bd7 quite quite
interesting alright so I'm only got one
more game to cover and this was the most
interesting game of
around corona against la camara y a
great matchup and also I'm look at if
you look at the tournament standings
both players are on on a blast score two
out of three and they both haven't
played the draw yet so 12 games lost one
so nice matchup let's see what happens
nakamura recently am pretty much relied
on the night officer his main defense
against if ye varies a lot of course but
the night office is really a fix a point
I'm looking forward here one of the
pillars of his opening repertoire is
playing this rather rather frequently ok
f3 and we should be three for the
English attack and here black has got
the main choice he has a night d7 Bishop
e7 looks like this but there's also h5
and this is one of those recent
interesting developments in opening
theory that maybe would have shocked
players like 30 years ago or at least
surprised yeah black place a flank porn
move h5 rather early instead of
developing something or I'm doing
something in the center but it's still
rather good idea the ideas some players
yeah it's a sort of a preemptive strike
against g4 and g4 is one of the main
ideas of why tg4 g5g for h 45 this porn
storm especially if I can scarcely long
and where else would you go then
black castle short of course not long if
black castle short what else are you
going to do so h5 is quite interesting
it prevents a key idea of white and this
also pretty much dices white to go for
short castles yeah here wyd went from 95
it's not strictly necessary to play this
move you can also play Bishop e2 for
example but ok 95 has been played before
it is in fact a standard motif in this
kind of position like takes with the
night to keep the bishops and now places
the bishop on l5c h5 is useful it's also
preventing G for now and this Bishop now
plays a useful role on this diagonal
this 95 move has some a classic really
classic approach in this structure
championed by Russian legend FM gala
back in the yes starting in the in the
50s and 60s when the night off was
becoming popular he was quite successful
with this idea just putting your knight
on d5 letting it capture and then the
upon goes to d5 and forms a four against
three majority on the queenside so at
this point so I'm White's ideas to use
his extra porn on the queenside in the
long run to play this kind of
breakthrough using the extra pony and we
see this happening in the game check
yeah this is in fact interesting Mike
I'm gonna ask you this check here very
quickly also probably all prep g3 and
then returns to f6 which surprised me
because it's quite uncommon to to get
your queen out here before you play Bush
should be seven in general in the night
or this is a very very uncommon maneuver
not saying that it's bad it's just not
frequently seen castles and Bishop e7 so
he's got the Queen out actively and now
white place night night to a five this
is in fact a very interesting position
and what wide wants to do once to play
c4 c4 c5 as mentioned but this is in
fact not so easy this night on b3 is
really blocking the beep on but they are
you're going to go you want to move the
night and make sure the pawns are
started to roll so what he did is he
advanced it and this is so not a bad
idea attacking be seven black needs to
react somehow and you cannot really play
b6 because the knight to c6 is just too
much don't want this piece on c600 black
so black master cover with luke c7 and
now he played first Bishop d3 and ce4 so
why does some realizing his plan black
exchanged and play the centralizing
booth white played before so how to
assess this position it's probably am
somewhere between um equal I am and
maybe why it has a little something I
MEF on first glance i was very much
preferring white but if you look look at
it a little bit a little bit more
closely you see that it's in fact
absolutely not not clear their various
things that are not helping
wyd one point is the slightly weakened
King side and especially they have three
Pawn so white cannot easily move the
Rope here or play something like this
because f3 is always yeah it needs some
protection black also has got the
irritating of h5 edge for at at the
later stage and in fact even this this
breakthrough with c4 c5 it is not easy
at all to to force through because black
is on it with lots of pieces really
probably all this is about equal but
it's very difficult to play and we see
after Bishop f8 looks e2 e1 yeah this
surprise me that you move away the rook
Adam it's not easy at all to make any
progressive right for example place the
night back here to support him then
black will play h4 with some counter
play possible if white now tries to
break through there's even this means as
a possibility because this is not
possible and what is why playing next
taking on d6 is really am giving up the
whole the whole position so it's not
clear at all not at all but i actually
prefer this to two loops e to e 1g six
normal move Wendy took winner five yeah
some of the screen maneuver h4 f6f five
led to an active post for the Queen so
it wasn't bad it seems a phone yeah by
now one problem is the night on a five I
mean it's it's doing something it's
always attacking the pawn and it's ready
to jump to c6 if black plays b6 but
another role of this night is to protect
the c-4 porn
you have a protection here and if white
wants to improve the night or use it
somewhere else there's always the c-4
point to worry about for example you'd
like to drop back actually and after h4
can I put ya Knight f6 was played white
wants to push this this this pawn and
you only maybe want to move the night
back to prepare that but then c4i
sanging again so it's not easy at all
for white to to make any progress it's
probably not bad his position but it's
very difficult to play to make any any
headway which would be six yeah drop
back and f1 get a surprise me but the
idea is that like probably needs to play
me for not that it's bad but this is the
idea and after eform white gets the good
square on d4 for his pieces so why does
okay Luke c7 and now he had this
position white as some is committing a
mistake in a very complicated position
he played the move h3 preparing g-form
it's an understandable move and
certainly a move that done let's say I
would have thought about in the in the
position black of course cannot take it
f6 the same but the problem is and this
is why why am this move was a mistake
it's Bishop g7 and this is played by
nakamura he covers this night this pawn
is hanging and there's also a third news
which you can try to find a small
exercise here and white needs to do
something else not one hundred percent
sure what's the best move
moves like this for example possible
okay but let's see what happened to h3
Bishop g7 Queen g2 and here black has a
very strong move that this is actually
something you can use as a small
exercise the the move that you need to
find alters the position fundamentally
it gives black a big advantage I'll be
quiet for a couple of seconds so that
you can pause the video and think for
yourself all right I'm giving the move
now and it's b5 very very strong move
the ideas you want to get rid of the sea
porn make it move and then black wins
the deep on it's a very very tricky
already why it took on b5 and that white
now takes over here then there's just 95
and black SS winning simply it's a it's
equal material for the moment but blacks
got to central passed pawns and those
those pieces are not doing much blackest
black is much better am almost close to
beneath the computer says it's when they
are a um so what is why it's supposed to
do if you cannot take your pawn on c4 is
as fast to do to move and in some way
and then the for the position falls
apart kawana tried to capture on f6 and
play g4 but after taking there's a check
on d4 very important King h2 and Queen
f6 and now black has got a baguette
she's got the strong pawn the strong
Bishop and there are ideas to even play
against the exposed King and in fact
after nine to c6 ship back
g5 Queen f5 um black was getting a
decisive attack white now try it some
desperation moves like this but after
taking simply on before and d6 Black has
roots III to have to look takes e4 like
simplified King g7 and prepared the
deadly check on AJ then why's it doesn't
even have have a check on his own to
somehow confuse matters like it's just
coming with ruga h8 winning the whole
thing so an excellent game when I can
work honey you get this if you I mean
this is really really strong if you look
at this game it's 40 moves or 39 moves
and if you check it with a comp it
doesn't even criticize 11 single move
like Amber astuces this is exceptionally
strong and it's also very instructive to
see this b5 move play to 2am um we had
to break down the center the whole
problem started with with this age three
meals of white plays a decent let's say
consolidating move I don't think he's in
in any big trouble I mean like is having
chances yeah but it's not like black is
better or winning or anything this is
really a helped helped of like black
quite a lot and I'm pretty sure I we see
now him here after Queen g2 is spent he
spent look the clock 17 minutes 25 12
minutes and was aware that okay I'm in
trouble now be five was coming of course
and now why this is falling apart so
very strong game Binaca winning winning
here against a very strong karana and
this means the cameras and I'm the sole
lead with three wins and one loss
three-year wins came after a disastrous
loss in round one and then he won three
in a row and after we're against Romney
key was very lucky but then he played a
good game
on Sunday winning and now winning again
he beat the kayaking and very nice green
felt on on on the Saturday and now this
very convincing win with black am in a
nice night off against kawana karana now
lost two white games in the night off
against against was a girlfriend yeah
against Gelfond and then this one so
karana lost two white games already
strangely enough all right so I hope you
like the round and some games weren't so
interesting but Nakamura played an
excellent game and we can look forward
to further interesting chess in this
tournament yeah thanks for watching I'll
be back tomorrow with round five
coverage